- Obviously, so much
of our story is built
on the hero's journey
of overcoming obstacle.
And yet, everything in
society today is telling us,
you know, conflict's not okay.
You know, challenge is not okay.
We've gotta be safe.
We've gotta be like prevented
from having challenges.
Whereas actually, it's
challenge that enables
the human spirit to
grow and to overcome.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the baroness at
the UK House of Lords
and the CEO of the Alliance
for Responsible Citizenship,
also known as ARC.
Baroness Philippa Stroud,
welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you so much, Dave,
really great to join you.
- Well I'm very
happy to have you
because I will be joining you
guys at the ARC conference
in London in about a week and
a half or two weeks or so.
And I thought we could
just chat for a few minutes
about what the
conference is all about,
sort of how this
originally came from the,
I think I can say the great
mind of Jordan Peterson,
what the genesis
of all of this was,
and what the intentions are.
So I'd love to talk to you
about British politics,
but I think we have
to focus on that.
So can you talk
about what ARC is,
how Jordan got to you,
and where you wanna
go with this thing?
- Yeah, thanks, Dave.
So ARC is really a
movement of people
who are basically saying
that we've had enough
of a declinist,
perma-crisis, poly-crisis
type way of thinking.
We actually believe that
there is a better story,
a better way forward, and
a more hopeful narrative.
And because we so
believe in story,
because it shapes who we are
and it shapes our direction
of travel as societies,
we actually want
to come together
to develop a better
story for our society.
But actually, when I think
back to how it all started,
I had invited Jordan
to come and do a talk
at the think tank
that I led in London.
And we had a fantastic
time with him.
The whole time we were
focused on freedom of speech
and higher education and how
we restore freedom of speech
and academic freedom
back to our universities.
And at the end of it,
he went on his way, did a big
tour around Eastern Europe.
And halfway through that
tour, he rang me and he said,
"Philippa, everywhere I go,
there are people,
fantastic leaders,
but they're so isolated.
And they're doing amazing work.
What would happen if we
brought them all together
to do a conference in London?"
And I thought, "Great story."
And at the end of it,
he just said to me,
"Philippa, do you know this
chap called Paul Marshall?"
And I said, "Yeah,
great friend of mine."
So I pinged an email and said,
"Hey, Jordan, meet
Paul. Paul, meet Jordan.
You're gonna love each other."
Next couple of days,
Paul rings me and says,
"You know this conference
that you and Jordan are doing?
I'm in," and I go,
(Dave laughing)
"What conference?"
Anyway, it kind of just
snowballed from there.
And you know when like
an idea's time has come,
it just has momentum behind it
and people wanting to get
onboard and make it happen?
That's what ARC has been
like from beginning to end.
- I have to say just on a
personal note, as you know,
I toured with Jordan
in 2018 and '19
about 120 shows, I
think 20 countries,
and what you just described
there of all these great people
coming up to him-
- Yeah.
- After the show,
political leaders,
politician-
- Yeah.
- Politicians, celebrities,
thinkers, authors.
Everyone was like, "We've
gotta do something."
So I'm so thrilled
for this thing.
I really can't wait.
But do you find it strange,
you mentioned stories,
and obviously, Jordan has
been a great explainer
of why stories are important.
You can't just
give people policy.
Do you find it
odd that the West,
which has come up with
so much great, you know,
movie making and
books and literature
and all of the stuff that
our culture is made of,
we somehow didn't tell a
story to defend ourselves?
Does that seem like a
strange dichotomy to you?
- Yeah, and it's like our
stories got so fragmented.
So one of the questions we're
going to be asking at ARC is:
What can we draw
from our history?
What is the
narrative, the story,
that can unite us
as we go forward?
And we're asking like
what story can be drawn
from our liberal
democratic history
and what story can be drawn
from our
Judeo-Christian history.
Are there stories that
actually can be foundational
to who we are that
can take us forward?
And obviously, so much
of our story is built
on the hero's journey
of overcoming obstacle.
And yet, everything in
society today is telling us,
you know, conflict's not okay.
You know, challenge is not okay.
We've gotta be safe.
We've gotta be like prevented
from having challenges.
Whereas actually, it's
challenge that enables
the human spirit to
grow and to overcome.
So there are lots of
different themes like this
that we're going to be
exploring at ARC as well.
- Right, and the conference
is, it's four days,
if I'm not mistaken?
Is it four full days?
- Yeah, it starts
on Sunday the 29th
and then it's going
through the 30th, 31st,
and 1st of November.
So Monday, Tuesday, and
Wednesday in London.
So exciting.
- Great, so we're gonna link
to it down below
because, obviously,
portions of it at least
are open to the public
and we want people to be there-
- Yeah.
- And all of that.
What other types?
Is it fair to call
it sort of a counter
to the World Economic Forum,
sort of a bottom up way
of looking at the world,
as opposed to top down version
of looking at the world?
- Yeah, so it is a gathering
of leaders in London,
but it's also really
profoundly built
around the principle
of subsidiarity.
So what am I responsible
for as an individual?
What is my family
responsible for?
What is my community
And then what is my
nation responsible for?
So instead of hiding
away somewhere
and coming up with
these big decisions,
then imposing them on society
and pushing them down,
it's very much coming
up from the principle
of responsibility
at every level,
including the individual.
And then on the night
of the 1st of November,
Jordan's throwing open the
doors at ARC at the O2,
huge place where anyone
can book a ticket.
I mean, it takes
20,000 people, ARC,
and it's literally open to
anyone who can get a ticket.
They're going very fast if
they haven't already gone.
- Right, and what are some
of the like categories
that you're gonna
be talking about?
So I think people
understand sorta broadly
what you're talking about,
but this is gonna
be about science,
it's gonna be about tech,
media, et cetera, right?
Like it's gonna be sort
of across all disciplines.
- Yeah.
So the big question
we're asking is:
What is the better story?
But within that too, it's like:
What is the better
story for family
and the social fabric?
What is the better
story for business?
What is the better story for
energy and the environment?
So it's asking right
across the board
all these like, what is
the better story in all
of these different
aspects of life.
There's so much that
we want to platform
that I think it's going to
take years two, three, four,
to platform it all.
But it's all going to be
framed around that lens
of the better story.
- And is the plan
then, I assume so,
but the plan will be,
okay, we're gonna come up
with sort of specific stories
that can lead us to policies?
And then we're gonna find-
- Yeah.
- The people that might
be in the House of Lords
or in the United States
Congress or elsewhere
and we're gonna try to
implement some of this stuff?
- Absolutely.
And what's really exciting too
is that we've got at least
half the shadow cabinet
from Australia coming.
Three ex-Australia prime
ministers are coming.
We've got two congressional
delegations coming
from the US.
We've got over 100 different MPs
from different parts
of the world coming.
So we have some people
of real influence,
but we also have 200
business leaders,
another 200 kind of ideas
and influencers as well.
So I mean, it's going to be
a very rich, rich audience.
- Do you think there's
anyone in the world
that could've pulled
something like this off
other than Jordan?
Like when I first heard
about this, I was like,
"Oh, this is what Jordan
was supposed to do."
It just seems so
obvious to me in a way.
- I mean, he's a
remarkable, you know this,
he's a remarkable individual.
And I love working with him.
I think he's an
extraordinary man.
But what's been really
great in the ARC conference
is the ability to gather
other like-minded,
extraordinary people too.
We've got over 90 speakers
who are going to be platformed,
people wanting to come and be
on the stage and contribute.
And I think, you know,
this sort of change, Jordan
would be the first person to say
it can't be through one person.
It has to be through
a movement of people.
But oh my word, he's been the
most extraordinary catalyst.
- Does it also feel to you that
the timing is kind of right,
not just because of-
- Yeah.
- What's been
happening in the world
for the last couple
years, obviously,
but really, even the events
of the last 10 days or so
really have the West
feeling very shaken.
I mean, I'm seeing
obviously the protests
that are happening in London,
but they're happening
here in New York City
and other places here as well.
- Yeah.
I would really agree
with you, Dave.
I think one of the questions
that we're asking is:
Where did we lose
our confidence?
And how did we lose
our values in the West?
And would these
events be happening
if we had more confidence
in who we are as people,
more confidence in our values?
And I think we've got, you
know, fantastic historians
like Niall Ferguson who
are going to be joining us.
We're hoping that we will have
some extraordinary
spokespeople even from Israel
who are able to join us
that aren't announced yet.
And obviously, for
obvious reasons,
may not be able to join us.
But I think this
is a moment for us
to really ask ourselves some
difficult questions and say,
"Actually, we've got to
strengthen ourselves.
We've got to have more courage.
We've got to have a
better story to tell."
- I think, actually, we
should leave it there
so that people will
hear a small bite
and then, of course, we're
gonna be recording everything.
And there'll be all sorts
of videos that'll get out.
I'm gonna try to do some
interviews on the ground,
even if I gotta do
it from an iPhone.
We'll chat with everybody there,
and I just wanna thank you
for putting this together
and working with Jordan on this.
A link to the tickets to the
O2 event are right below.
Do you have any final
thoughts before I let you go?
- No, just can't
wait to welcome you
to London, Dave, as well.
- I can't wait,
thank you so much.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop screaming,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.